mencioné de los vídeos anteriores que el
coeficiente de fricción cinética o k
tiende a ser menor o igual que el
coeficiente de fricción estática pero
esto bueno puede llevarnos a preguntarse
pues por qué está sucediendo esto y la
mejor teoría hasta el momento al menos
la que mejor se puede imaginar a un
nivel comprensible humanamente es este
imaginen que tenemos aquí un bloque
que se encuentra estático
y está encima de una superficie
más o menos así
y por otro lado tenemos otro bloque que
va a estar encima de otra superficie
y es el mismo material que tiene el que
está hecho el bloque el mismo material
que está hecha la superficie y la masa
del bloque también es la misma en ambos
casos pero en este otro caso le estamos
a este bloque está moviéndose
y tiene una cierta velocidad constante
en relación con esta misma superficie
y como les comenté asumiendo que tienen
las mismas masas son las mismas
superficies y los mismos materiales el
coeficiente de fricción estacionario en
este caso
estacionario
es mayor que el coeficiente de fricción
cinética es que es en este caso
otra forma de verlo es que se
necesitaría aplicar más fuerza para
superar la fricción estática
que para lograr lo que se acelere o
aumenta la aceleración de un bloque que
ya se encuentra en movimiento vamos a
hacer un zoom o acercarnos y tratar de
ver esto a nivel molecular
así que así en un nivel
imposible para el ojo humano pero bueno
vamos a tratar de imaginar
supongamos que voy a dibujar las
moléculas o los átomos que conforman lo
que están en esta superficie entonces
pues bueno podrían verse
así más o menos
algo así
cada una de estas bolitas es una
molécula o incluso puede ser un dato a
nivel molecular y el nivel atómico
ninguna superficie es parejita basilisa
siempre van a ver pues bueno estas
imperfecciones y voy a tratar de dibujar
ahora la superficie de como que está en
contacto del bloque con el suelo sobre
el que está y ahora bueno voy a dibujar
estos son las moléculas
del bloque
que está encima de esta superficie
entonces no se puede ser
también es bastante irregular
algo así más o menos no están totalmente
alineados
y bueno también quiero mostrar en este
vídeo que todas las fuerzas y estos
contactos que hemos estado hablando en
los últimos vídeos pues en realidad no
están verdaderamente tocándose tenemos
átomos que se estan repeliendo
mutuamente porque sus electrones se
repelen debido a la fuerza
electromagnética y eso es lo que evita
que se acerquen o se toquen cuando
ustedes empujen algo en realidad es que
la nube de electrones en su mano empujan
a la nube de electrones de la pluma que
sostienen o de la tecla de su teclado en
la computadora lo repelen ocasionando
que vaya en otra dirección así que nunca
se tocan en la realidad y si quieren
asombrarse de verdad pueden ver los
vídeos de química de khan academy en
donde se explica que estos átomos tienen
en su mayor parte espacio vacío entre
sus componentes la nube de electrones es
enorme la probabilidad de encontrar un
electrón en la nube es muy pequeña
debido al tamaño de la nube comparada
con el tamaño del electrón o de su
núcleo del núcleo del átomo por lo que
tenemos espacio y empujando a otro
espacio vacío debido a la fuerza
electromagnética
pero bueno regresemos a nuestro tema de
flexión al acercarnos a esto cuando está
estacionario veamos que estas
superficies no son lisas así que podemos
imaginarnos que algunas de estas
moléculas están dentro de los huecos
entre las otras moléculas de la
superficie por lo que si queremos mover
esto pues tendremos que superar
estas barreras como en este caso
tendremos que romper esta parte de las
moléculas o levantar esto un poco para
que estos supere estas anguita
a lo mejor no se tienen que reacomodar
estas moléculas para que puedan moverse
y esto es lo que nos va a ocasionar
la fricción o que este coeficiente de
fricción estática sea más grande por
tener que estar superando estas cositas
que del material que ya está asentado
encima de las otras moléculas y esos
otros huecos
que si tenemos el material movimiento
ahora voy a tratar de dibujar más o
menos la misma superficie pero en este
caso de que se está moviendo el bloque
más o menos que sea parecido
a este otro caso que dibuje aquí junto
más o menos
y vamos a dibujar también las
con moléculas de la superficie de este
bloque pero ya se está moviendo aquí
no tienen tiempo estas moléculas
de asentarse o poder entrar
en estos otros huecos de la superficie
donde ésta se está moviendo todo esto de
cierta manera ya tiene una inclinación o
está acomodado de tal manera que éstos
no tienen tiempo de asentarse sino se
van moviendo en relación a los con otros
entonces aunque seguimos teniendo una
fuerza de fricción pues del zinc cuando
algunas de estas moléculas caerán o
coincidirán con estos huecos pues
también existen todo tipo de enlaces
químicos que se forman temporalmente
entre los átomos que mantienen
formándose y destruyéndose para mantener
esto en movimiento cuando esto esté
estático no sólo hay que romper esos
enlaces químicos perdón por esta imagen
que apareció
también hay que superar las partes que
quedan atrapadas o que queden
entrelazadas en estos huecos por eso hay
que aplicar más fuerza en esta parte
cuando esté estático que aquí que bueno
ya no les da tiempo para compenetrarse
tanto entonces esta fuerza o digamos que
no hay tantas trabas para que estos
materiales puedan moverse
esto es en esencia lo que se ha
encontrado hasta el momento para
explicar la fricción aunque perdona
luego se realizan todavía muchas
investigaciones pues para investigar el
por qué este coeficiente de fricción
estática es ligeramente mayor que esta
fricción simétrica